The normal way we set about trying to extend
our lives is by striving to add more years
to them – usually by eating more couscous
and broccoli, going to bed early and running
in the rain. But this approach may turn out
to be quixotic, not only because Death can’t
reliably be warded off with kale, but at a
deeper level, because the best way to lengthen
a life is not by attempting to stick more
years on to its tail. One of the most basic
facts about time is that, even though we insist
on measuring it as if it were an objective
unit, it doesn’t, in all conditions, feel
as if it were moving at the same pace. Five
minutes can feel like an hour; ten hours can
feel like five minutes. A decade may pass
like two years; two years may acquire the
weight of half a century. And so on. In other
words, our subjective experience of time bears
precious little relation to the way we like
to measure it on a clock. Time moves more
or less slowly according to the vagaries of
the human mind: it may fly or it may drag.
It may evaporate into airy nothing or achieve
enduring density. If the goal is to have a
longer life, whatever the dieticians may urge,
it seems like the priority should not be to
add raw increments of time but to ensure that
whatever years remain feel appropriately substantial.
The aim should be to densify time rather than
to try to extract one or two more years from
the fickle grip of Death. Why then does time
have such different speeds, moving at certain
points bewilderingly fast, at others with
intricate moderation? The clue is to be found
childhood. The first ten years almost invariably
feel longer than any other decade we have
on earth. The teens are a little faster but
still crawl. Yet by our 40s, time will have
started to trot; and by our 60s, it will be
unfolding at a bewildering gallop. The difference in pace
is not mysterious: it has to do with novelty.
The more our days are filled with new, unpredictable
and challenging experiences, the longer they
will feel. And, conversely, the more one day
is exactly like another, the faster it will
pass by in an evanescent blur. Childhood ends
up feeling so long because it is the cauldron
of novelty; because its most ordinary days
are packed with extraordinary discoveries
and sensations: these can be as apparently
minor yet as significant as the first time
we explore the zip on a cardigan or hold our
nose under water, the first time we look at
the sun through the cotton of a beach towel
or dig our fingers into the putty holding
a window in its frame. Dense as it is with
stimuli, the first decade might as well be
a thousand years long. By middle age, things
can be counted upon to have grown a lot more
familiar. We may have flown around the world
a few times. We no longer get excited by the
idea of eating a pineapple, owning a car or
flipping a lightswitch. We know about relationships,
earning money and telling others what do.
And as a result, time runs away from us without
mercy. One solution often suggested at this
point is that we should put all our efforts
into discovering fresh sources of novelty.
We can’t just continue to live our small
predictable and therefore ‘swift’ lives
in a single narrow domain; we need to become
explorers and adventurers. We must go to Machu
Picchu or Angkor Wat, Astana or Montevideo,
we need to find a way to swim with dolphins
or order a thirteen course meal at a world-famous
restaurant in downtown Lima. That will finally
slow down the cruel gallop of time. But this
is to labour under an unfair, expensive and
ultimately impractical notion of novelty.
We may by middle age certainly have seen a
great many things in our neighborhoods, but
we are – fortunately for us – unlikely
to have properly noticed most of them. We
have probably taken a few cursory glances
at the miracles of existence that lie to hand
and assumed, quite unjustly, that we know
all there is to know about them. We’ve imagined
we understand the city we live in, the people
we interact with and, more or less, the point
of it all. But of course we have barely scratched
the surface. We have grown bored of a world
we haven’t begun to study properly. And
that, among other things, is why time is racing
by. The pioneers at making life feel longer
in the way that counts are not dieticians,
but artists. At its best, art is a tool that
reminds us of how little we have fathomed
and noticed. It re-introduces us to ordinary
things and reopens our eyes to a latent beauty
and interest in precisely those areas we had
ceased to bother with. It helps us to recover
some of the manic sensitivity we had as newborns.
Here is Cezanne, looking closely at apples,
as if he had never seen one before and nudging
us to do likewise: Here is Van Gogh, mesmerised
by some oranges: Here is Albrecht Durer, looking
– as only children usually do – very closely
at a clod of earth:
We don’t need to make art
in order to learn the most valuable lesson
of artists, which is about noticing properly,
living with our eyes open – and thereby,
along the way, savouring time. Without any
intention to create something that could be
put in a gallery, we could – as part of
a goal of living more deliberately – take
a walk in an unfamiliar part of town, ask
an old friend about a side of their life we’d
never dared to probe at, lie on our back in
the garden and look up at the stars or hold
our partner in a way we never tried before.
It takes a rabid lack of imagination to think
we have to go to Machu Picchu to find something
new. In Fyodor Dostoevsky’s novel The Idiot,
a prisoner has suddenly been condemned to
death and been told he has only a few minutes
left to live. ‘What if I were not to die!,’
he exclaims. ‘What if life were given back
to me – what infinity!… I’d turn a whole
minute into an age…’ Faced with losing
his life, the poor wretch recognises that
every minute could be turned into aeons of
time, with sufficient imagination and appreciation.
It is sensible enough to try to live longer
lives. But we are working with a false notion
of what long really means. We might live to
be a thousand years old and still complain
that it had all rushed by too fast. We should
be aiming to lead lives that feel long because
we have managed to imbue them with the right
sort of open-hearted appreciation and unsnobbish
receptivity, the kind that five-year-olds
know naturally how to bring to bear. We need
to pause and look at one another’s faces,
study the evening sky, wonder at the eddies
and colours of the river and dare to ask the
kind of questions that open our souls. We
don’t need to add years; we need to densify
the time we have left by ensuring that every
day is lived consciously – and we can do
this via a manoeuvre as simple as it is momentous:
by starting to notice all that we have as
yet only seen.
Our Wisdom Display Cards explore what it really means to be wise and how we can strive to become more enlightened in our every day lives.